the demonstration in Paris began outside
the French Senate protestors want
senators to change a proposed law that
would allow access to either F for
single and gay women not just those in a
heterosexual couple
they say the French government's new
bioethics bill would deprive children of
the father and destroy the moral fabric
of French society and some worry could
be expanded to legalize surrogacy the
law doesn't take into account at all the
right of the child or its future it only
accounts for a woman's desire to have a
child it's important to defend the
family unit a mother and a father for
the balance of French society and for
children's welfare the March was
peaceful but police officers broke up a
small counter protest the controversial
bill has divided opinion in September
French MPs approved it but only after a
fiery debate or the report how dare you
decide to inscribe in to know that a
child be deprived of a father this
shocks me yes I mean notional you are
playing with fire go to protest against
gay marriage but for supporters of the
proposed law they say it would be a
victory for women's rights when she
reached her mid-30s benedict blase
wanted to become a mother as a single
woman she was unable to access ICF in
France so she travelled to Denmark and
Portugal where the treatment is legally
available to all women I felt out low in
my own country because I just wanted a
baby and that right was okay in other
European countries but not in France
Benedict's son is now 14 months old
father first say all that matters is
love and though the fact that he was
wanted
if the bioethics bill becomes law it
will fulfill one of French presidents
Emmanuel macron campaign promises and
create hope for single and gay women who
dream of becoming a parent but these
protesters say
they won't give up their battle to
protect traditional family values and
stop the legislation from being passed
Natasha Butler al-jazeera Paris